I you know I was fun to be objectified
for a day it's like my I was thinking I
got women it's happened to women so so
so much
[Music]
you know man
yeah yeah that look like huh
can we talk about the Amazon pools let's
just get straight to it yeah it's only
right and I wasn't mad at becae yeah I
always get objectified in a nice I only
write there was really no script when I
first signed on to it one of the first
things she talked about was the scene
and I come out of these the rock pools
and I'm kind of you know I've been in
war now I'm in this great place full of
beautiful women and a hot tub and I'm
thinking God isn't that so bad and
there's a whole line about being average
or above average I just thought was so
stupid but so funny and so male you know
so I thought oh man this is something
this is a good joke that joke alone I
was like I think I'll I think I may do
this movie just for that well that was
fun I think the most compassion I've
felt toward women for what they may feel
is being sidelined or whatever made less
important or made to feel less not your
life but it's funny to ask someone like
me because I'm a man and I get it I
don't take any umbrage to it at all but
I do now have a great amount of
compassion for for women or disempowered
there's a disempowerment that happens
there welcome to our world
yeah yeah pardon me reinforcements can
we talk about Chris Pine and Amazon
Poole I mean did he did you do it in one
take did he just walk around with his
hand no no no no I have no idea if he's
above average or not okay this is nice
it wasn't it was covered okay um but he
came very prepared did you have on a
banana hammock yeah of course I did
anything I was walking around with a
full thing oh my god you just had your
handsome oh man I know I did a lot of
sock stuffing making sure I looked as as
fit as a fiddle above-average as
possible
[Music]
you